this video is about cox proportional
hazard survival regression or cox
regression for short so let's start
right away with the first question
what is cox regression
cox regression is used in survival
analysis to determine the influence of
different variables on survival time
this is done with the cox proportional
hazards model so what exactly is
survival time analysis
in survival time analysis the survival
times of subjects are measured and a
survival curve is plotted
usually the subjects have some kind of
disease the survival curve then shows
how many of the subtexts remain alive
over time
the time considered does not have
anything to do with the survival time
nevertheless one speaks of the survival
time and the survival time analysis
generalized we can say in survival time
analysis a variable is considered that
has a start time and when a certain
event occurs an end time the time
between the start time and the event is
considered in the survival time analysis
the time can be measured for example in
days weeks or months
now of course there is the big problem
that a study has limited resources for
resource reasons and simply because one
wants to publish the results at some
point there is a start and an end date
of a study if a case does not have a
definite event it is referred to as
censored several methods have been
developed to deal with this issue please
have a look at my video on the
kaplan-meier curve but now back to the
cox regression for example if you want
to analyze survival time after a disease
is detected
you are often not interested in survival
time per se but in what has an influence
on survival time so we want to know if
survival time depends on one or more
factors the so-called predictors for
simple situations with a single factor
with only two values
the log rank test is used so for example
if you want to test whether there is a
difference in survival time when two
different drugs are given to a patient
however if you want to include the age
of the subjects for example
a special type of regression is needed
namely the proportional hazard survival
regression the regression should then
evaluate the effects of the individual
protectors on the shape of the survival
curve
so as predictors we have the drug used
and the age of the person
we now want to know what influence these
variables have on the survival time
curve and we do this with the cox
regression let's look at an example
let's assume this is our data we want to
evaluate each row describes a patient
with the corresponding disease
the time indicates when the event or
death occurred here we have the data
which track was used and here we have
the age of the people
in the first step we must now calculate
the cox regression which we do online
with data tab
then we go through how to interpret the
results to calculate the cox
proportional hazard survival regression
we simply go to datadept.net and copy
our data into this table just copy and
paste as in excel now we click on
survival analysis under this tab
depending on which variables you click
on
different methods of survival analysis
will be calculated if you only click on
the time and the status
the kaplan maya curve will be displayed
if you click on the drag you will get
the log rank test
and if you click on the age you will get
the cox regression here below you get
the results let's have a closer look at
it
the first column contains the names of
the variables
the first row indicates the variable
drag and the second row indicates the h
most important of this table is the
estimated regression coefficient
and the p-value with the p-value you can
see if the regression coefficient
is significantly different from zero so
the null hypothesis is in the population
the coefficient is zero let's say as
usual that we set our significance level
at five percent
then for p values less than five percent
or
0.05 the null hypothesis is rejected and
the coefficient is significantly
different from zero
in the case of drag the p-value is less
than 0.05 and therefore we have a
significant difference from 0. in the
case of h we get a p-value of
0.221 which is greater than 0.05
therefore in this case the null
hypothesis is not rejected and we assume
from this data that age has no
significant effect on the survival curve
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time